嘿，你猜中國現在流行什麼最新的行銷手法？出乎意料，他們竟然把「AI運算力」拿來當贈品、當獎勵，甚至變成一種新的支付方式。
等等，AI運算力？你是說像 ChatGPT 那種 AI 模型背後的運算量嗎？這怎麼可能當贈品？聽起來有點天方夜譚吧。一般人誰會想要那個？
我一開始也覺得奇怪，但原文提到，中國的商家，像是咖啡廳、餃子館，還有銀行跟電信公司，真的在這樣做。舉個例子，北京有間叫 AGI Bar 的，你買杯飲料，連結他們的 Wi-Fi，就可以無限使用 DeepSeek V4 Flash 這個 AI 模型。
買咖啡送 AI 算力？這會有人買單嗎？我覺得這只有寫程式或 AI 相關的人會感興趣吧。一般的消費者，誰會在意咖啡加送多少 AI tokens？
但它的客群就是鎖定程式設計師和 AI 新創公司的創辦人啊。而且，你看北京的「聚福園餃子館」也這麼做，吃完飯結帳，給你 10 塊人民幣的運算點數。他們桌上的小卡片還寫著：「你吃飽了餃子，也讓你的 AI 助手吃飽算力吧！」
餃子館也跟風，這就有點意思了。所以它不是直接給錢，而是給一種「可以讓你使用 AI」的額度？不過，這對普通人來說，有多少實用價值？我猜這種行銷模式很難持久。
原文寫到，光是那家餃子館的兩間店，每天就送出超過一百張這樣的券。而且這不只是一些小店在玩，連中國的三大電信公司，中國電信、中國移動和中國聯通，都推出像手機流量方案一樣的 AI 算力套餐。
電信公司也進場？這點我是信了，畢竟他們從賣電話卡到賣上網流量，現在賣 AI 算力，聽起來像一種業務延伸。但它真的能成為主流商品嗎？這算力怎麼計價，還有，消費者會搞懂他們拿到多少「算力」嗎？
像中國電信，它有推出每月 9.9 人民幣的方案，給你 1000 萬個 tokens。甚至你刷信用卡也能累積 AI tokens。中國的 Moonshot AI 就跟農業銀行、美國運通合作發行了一張聯名卡，刷卡消費就能賺 Kimi AI tokens。
信用卡也來這套？這跟累積里程或現金回饋差不多概念了，只是把獎勵換成 AI 算力。但我還是覺得，這種「算力」的價值波動性太大了，今天值錢，明天可能就不值錢了。銀行會願意承擔這種風險嗎？
他們其實是將 AI 算力視為一種「數位資產」，而且這種做法連銀行貸款都能用上了。廣州的海珠區就推出了「算力貸」這種金融產品，銀行可以根據 AI 新創公司生產和消耗的 tokens 數量，來評估他們的貸款額度。
哇，算力變成了信用資產，這確實是很出乎意料的發展。這樣聽起來，AI tokens 就不只是促銷品，它背後是真的有潛在價值在運作了。那我如果是一般中小企業主，能從這裡學到什麼？
我覺得最關鍵的是，它讓我們看到，AI 不只是一種工具，還能被包裝成一種新奇的「商品」或「行銷資產」。以前我們可能送點數、送折價券，現在，為什麼不試著送一些結合新科技的「服務額度」呢？
你的意思是，像健身房可以送智慧教練的「諮詢時數」，或是線上課程可以送 AI 助教的「輔導分鐘」？這樣聽起來，好像為我們的商品或服務增加了數位化的附加價值。
對啊！特別是服務業和零售業，思考一下，有沒有什麼是你的目標客群「可能需要」但「沒想到可以這樣得到」的數位服務或資源？把這些作為你的行銷噱頭或忠誠度獎勵，創造話題。
所以，如果我是一般上班族，這概念能怎麼帶入工作或生活呢？我總不能跟老闆說「我要送客戶 AI 算力」吧？
嗯，我猜啦，這可以提醒我們，在自己的工作領域裡，有沒有什麼「常規」但「沒被這樣思考過」的資源，是可以被重新包裝、賦予新價值，甚至變成一種獎勵或流通資產的。
重新思考資源的價值和可能性，這點確實不容易做到。
對。其實，這好像也提醒了我們，未來很多東西的價值評估，可能不再侷限於實體或金錢，數位化的「服務能力」或「算力」都會成為新的衡量標準。